in June 2015 I went to Sheffield's I saw
a Paternoster list and obsolete design
of elevator with a looping chain of open
cabs in June 2016 I traveled to Genoa in
Italy and I saw an elevator that also
moved sideways except spoiler it's a bit
of a cheat it's actually a little
horizontal card moves inside a bigger
elevator that does the heavy lifting and
now it is June 2017 and I'm in Germany
at the brand-new thyssen krupp
elevated test tower and they have flown
me out here to show off multi their
actual full-size working elevator that
moves sideways without cheating plus it
was very important to have a tower to
test the new technology we don't want to
test it at the customer side the tower
is 246 meters high and this means 1,700
steps I know that exactly because I woke
up once this is a building made almost
entirely of elevator shaft
some of them test regular lifts but some
of them are reserved for this new system
the principle of having a continuous
rotating flow of chorus was one of the
best inventions in our industry ever and
to achieve this we have to exchange
cabins from one shaft to another and to
have this exchange we need an exchange
or you see just behind me when this
exchanger allows us to go into the
horizontal movement exchanger can be
placed at every point in the shaft so it
allows us to do all kinds of
configurations coming down vertically
and then going into the horizontal
movement one of the problems with
elevators in really tall buildings is
that you need a cable so long that it
can't support its own weight let alone
the weight of the cabinets and connected
to it the solution here is a bit
different it doesn't use cables at all
it uses linear induction motors linear
drive is also a synchronous motor with
permanent magnets and you maybe know it
from a rotating motor we just take this
motor and cut it on one side and just
laid on the table flat then you already
have a linear drive and
is what we have vertical and also
horizontal in a regular elevator it's
called a traction elevator you've got
cables holding the cab any one of which
can hold more than the design weight
also you've got emergency brakes which
will pop out and slow the car down with
friction if it's moving too fast an
absolute worst case even if all that
somehow fails you have a buffer at the
bottom that should reduce a freefall
drop from fatal to just severe injuries
elevators are incredibly safe because
they're incredibly well regulated so
before this is allowed to carry humans
this system needs to be at least as
failsafe the safety is not just in the
ropes of a conventional elevator but in
the brake system in conventional
elevators you have the brake on the
machine on top of the shaft in the
machine room now we have the brake
directly on the cars this new component
the exchanger where we go from vertical
into horizontal movement also needs to
be checked by our safety controller what
is the position of the exchanger is it
locked
is it safe and in case any violation of
a safety rule then we go to a safe State
there are of course some caches linear
induction motors are expensive and heavy
each one other cabs needs to have its
own set and the whole elevator shaft
from top to bottom needs to be lined
with the magnetic coil units that power
them to save weight these cabs are made
of carbon fibre and aluminium so what
work out in the real world testing for
UPS models say well but once
everything's been casted and approved
here the next step is to sell it to the
kind of enormous multinational companies
who build skyscrapers and who do not
like risk and that might be a greater
challenge making the elevators in the
first place thank you very much to all
the team at testing properly invited me
over here you can pull down the
description for more about multi
you